marie thérèse fortin vous avez toujours
jouer des personnages accessibles les
gens la maison on a l'impression de vous
connaître
je les très beaux souvenirs de new york
mais aussi un bâtisseur mieux justin
morgan et joue le rôle d'une radio
oncologue clair dans mémoire vive et
c'est vraiment une série qui a marqué
l'imaginaire collectif
c'est un rôle qui a changé votre
carrière votre vie c'est quand tu
apprends que ça se termine que tu
réalises à quel point ça prix de la
place dans ta vie bon c'est là que tu
dis oh mon dieu je me suis levé souvent
avec la ramenait très tôt dès fois au
bras de sur le plateau de tournage
et puis les liens que tu développes
aussi avec les partenaires qui sont pas
seulement les partenaires tout à coup
c'est affi et que les jeunes comédiens
qui jouent à mes filles sont quasi
devenus mes filles ce plateau j'avais un
peu un réflexe maternelle avec l île et
événements nous voir si que comme
intéressant donc c'est sûr que ces
personnages là nous une chance nous nous
habite et puis et puis amman et bien sûr
il faut leur dire au revoir mais
qu'est-ce qui vient compenser tout cela
la gratification de l'impact qu'ils ont
eue sur le public et les commentaires
des spectateurs d'un téléspectateur
ah oui bon on on ou non les six nuls et
parfois quand les voir pendant votre
longue carrière on vous a vu à la
télévision dans quatre et demi et pezi
barbara
merci pour la franchise je voulais pas
te faire de peine gisèle mois peut
appeler ça mais où et les bas de sophie
paquin entre autres et pendant tout ce
temps là vous étiez mères d'enfants de
jeanjean fin d'adolescents maintenant
ils sont rendus vieux la question
lorsque les enfants sont grands
parce qu'on a plus de temps pour créer
pour penser ce que ça a changé votre
démarche artistique la façon de voir
votre or oui oui il avait neigé la
veille neige molle qui fondait saoulé
par une sorte de bouillie salle mon solo
autour de gabriel owa est amie au moment
où ma fille allait quitter la maison
c'était pas planifié comme ça mais il ya
eu on devrait organiquement quelque
chose qui s'est fait le nécessaire est
plus précieux à l'être humain que sa
liberté
c'est vrai que ça ouvre sur d'autres
possibilités au niveau de l'esprit ou
s'ils ne serait-ce que de préparer des
choses projets à venir dans vie qu'on a
parce que je prends de l'âge aussi de
dire telle personne avec qui j'ai jamais
travaillé que j'aurais dont envie de
travailler avec elle ici par exemple la
première fois je jouais à la licorne
donc ça c'est formidable pour moi parce
que c'est d'aller dans des lieux aussi
que j'ai pas encore inconnue dans
l'intérieur donc oui c'est vrai que ça
fait plus de place oui j'ai une autre
entrevue avec la radio russe avant
d'aller répéter tordo alors nous
vous avez toujours chanté c'est
important pour vous vous avez deux
spectacles un sur piaf 1 sur marc barrât
comment vous avez découvert barbe à un
accident gt gt dans un café j'étais au
cégep de matane et puis je savais pas ce
que je voulais faire dans la vie il est
comme puis là je buvais d expression je
découvrais les expressions j'en ai
beaucoup trop bu et et tout à coup dans
ce café ça c'est méchant tu sais je suis
qui se jettent tout de suite été
accroché par sa voix car cette mélodie
locke j'ai fait ce qu'ils puissent
quelqu'un tu connais personne me prêter
c'est juste que là j'ai écouté sa mère
comme une malade pas mal
[Musique]
et c'était une période où je me
cherchais beaucoup donc ça marche est
complète
ça ne parlait fort trop fort donc épicé
reste et ça m'a toujours un peu
accompagné pas prêt j'ai vu des
reportages à la télé avec elle et puis
après je les ai vus en spectacle à
québec en 87 qui ça a été un choc
incroyable pierre elle était déjà quand
même assez âge à l'époque mais c'était
une bête de scène jamais parce que
c'était le maître de saint avant d'avoir
vu par marc a aussi vu de replonger dans
ses chansons c'est toujours la même
émotion je peux rien
[Musique]
au printemps 2010 9 on va vous voir dans
l'adaptation du récit le monstre
d'ingres et de vallauris ça c'est
l'histoire d'une femme qui était battu
et violé par son amoureux violences
conjugales violences conjugales
comment cette histoire vous êtes
toujours je sais ça me touche beaucoup
ces sujets là je deviens faucher vite
vite vite et donc quand on m'a approché
chantal m'a dit tu sais je fais surtout
le cas du jeu fait une adaptation tous
âges et au caire mais c'est une bonne
équipe et on m'a envoyé le scénario
hélas j'ai lu pour la première fois et
j'ai vraiment été vraiment bouleversée
je n'en revenais pas de ce que je disais
et je trouvais que c'était surtout très
important de témoigner de ces choses là
aussi terrible que cette réaliser le thé
leurs puces à être parce que je pense
que c'était ça suffit je ça suffit a
aucune femme qui est obligé de subir ça
c'est un sujet terrible terrible mais
dont il faut absolument parler je pense
que c'est ce projet l'oeuvre vraiment va
vraiment permettre de mettre les cartes
sur table et de de faire face à la
musique et j'espère que collectivement
on va être capable de faire marie
thérèse fortin
merci c'est un plaisir merci